what do you think what do you think is
the
uh uh do you have a son or or you said
73 right 73 he's born 73 she's 68 yeah
okay so the son that's 73 he asks you
that
what do you think is the purpose of a
man in like what is my purpose what am i
supposed to do like if you were and i
know you're gonna say to each his own
everybody's different
some it's being this someone's being
that like
what is my you know
what what what purpose do i serve in
this world what am i supposed to be
seeking in life why am i here
if i if i'm your son and i ask you the
question what do you tell them well i
think i think like many other questions
that are being asked today especially
in social media
the question is ceremonial modern is
substantive
i don't think i've ever had a
conversation in which my son would pose
the question what is my purpose as a man
in life
um you only have one son if you have a
few more if
you were to pose that question i would
say hey dumbo look at your grandfather
imitate that
in fact i think i've said exactly that
your grandfather is a model of what a
man should be
why
because unyieldingly tough resourceful
highly intelligent honorable
fought in the foreign legion got my
mother out of germany got my mother out
of france crossed the pyrenees on foot
made a new life in the united states
and uh
was enormously proud of the fact that he
was one of the few jews in 1940 to face
the germans with a submachine gun in his
hands that's enough to be respect of
course salute at the highest level yeah
yeah so that's if my son were
to ask the question how do i be a man
imitate your grandfather uh david so
remember how i ask you the question what
are some of the heaviest questions at
this age where you're at
what what are some things some strong
convictions you had in your 20s 30s 40s
50s 60 whatever you pick it
that now it's kind of like you know yeah
it's not that important you know i used
to think xyz was so important it's
really not that big with you that's a
that's a very good question
except for the the concluding part i i
don't have many where i say it's not
that important but i have i have many
convictions i can remember
from the 60s
i was like you were 60 or in the 1960s
in the 90s
okay
you've got to remember i was not a baby
woman i was born in 42 so i was three
years older than the generation
to which i was exposed in the classroom
and
i have to say my own defense i was very
suspicious of the 1960s although i
participated enthusiastically and i
encouraged my students to rip up their
draft card while keeping mine pristine
condition
god forbid i should go to jail for my
convictions
and
when i heard in 1964 the rolling stones
painted black which was a a very popular
song of the 19th early 1960s i realized
that the sexual revolution was imminent
was about to break loose and
didn't take a whole lot of perspicacity
to realize that
but i must say that all of those
impulses
hedonistic impulses
which seem to make so much sense destroy
everything rebuild everything on a
peaceful sexually enlightened basis the
hell with the family the hell with
commitments the hell with patriotic
concerns simply develop your own
sensibility and live as gloriously as
possible in the satisfaction of any
desire no matter how vagrant remote or
degraded that was part of the 60s and it
came to catastrophe
the 60s did not end well we did
incredible incalculable damage to
american society in the 60s and i
watched it all happen i was far too
jejune or
even stupid to recognize it in front of
me even my objections to the vietnam war
were pure isle
and i thought i thought the vietnam war
was a catastrophe because i was 1a
i certainly wasn't about to go off to
vietnam to see my own ass blown off that
was out of the question
my father did not approve of that
attitude
he did not approve of that attitude
he didn't say anything but
you know every son can feel a father's
disapproval
um
he thought there was something
scandalous about not being unwilling to
defend your country by joining the
military
looking back i'm not really prepared to
make a judgment to this day i don't
think the vietnam war has received the
kind of scholarly attention
that it really does deserve it's too
early i mean the vietnam war ended in
1973-1974 it's going to take a hundred
years before we really understand
the wars indo-chinese wars of succession
and don't forget they began in 1945
the french were chased out then the
americans were chased out
but i do think that in
1962-1963 and this remains an abiding
conviction
not quite an answer to your question but
perhaps illustrates the nature of the
question that no american president
could have done anything other than what
kennedy and johnson did do
i think that's that's true and that's
a very curious point because it puts the
entire structure of the anti-war
movement in a different perspective
i have a lot more respect now than i did
in the 60s for my father's attitude
about
honor demanding a willingness to serve a
lot more recently i got a lot of respect
for your for your father's uh a level of
appreciation as a patriot to what this
country probably
gave him and his family where he oh for
sure
you have no idea oh it's honorable to
have that mindset
if you enjoyed this short clip click
over here to watch another short clip
and if you want to watch the entire
episode the entire podcast click here
[Music]